do you guys remember
um when Chris Brown and Rihanna were in
that incident a couple years ago yeah
yeah I've been watching about that
recently to be fair but just updating
myself on it why do you think there was
a public outcry for Chris Brown and
Rihanna to the point that he was
canceled for a while and couldn't do
shows but there was no public outcry for
cardi B when she publicly admitted to
and robbing men I think because Chris
Brown's a guy save one looks at the guys
like the person who beat someone up is
not good but for a girl if you do that
you don't get the same but I feel like
the thing is obviously don't get me
wrong you shouldn't hurt or hit someone
but you don't know the underlying issues
it's all talk at the end of the day